a final debate among presidential
hopefuls in Rio de Janeiro
while many expected the two leading
candidates former president we see nacio
Lula de Silva
and incumbent candidate president
bolsonaro to provide details of their
political platforms the conversation
ended up being more about accusing each
other of lies and Corruption
this is insane the president of the
Republic comes here speaking nonsense
and that's why on October the 2nd the
people will send him home
this final presidential debate marked
the last time the candidates would meet
face to face before Brazilians head to
the polls on Sunday
for president bolsonaro this was also a
last chance to close the gap between
himself and his main rival former
president Lula who has maintained a
commanding lead according to polling
data
we're a government that tends to the
needs of the poorest during Lula's
government the poverty assistance was
less today there are 20 million families
that are receiving assistance from us in
Brazil
according to the most recent polls
former president Lula counts on some 50
percent of the vote which political
analysts like Sergio branches say could
be enough to win the presidency without
the need for a second round of voting
yeah I think that there is a likelihood
that Lula wins on the on the first run
it will depend on abstention
and how the very few undecided voters
will decide the vote this presidential
race has been one of the most polarizing
in Brazil's history one thing voters
here do agree on is that this election
represents a critical battle over the
future of Latin America's largest
democracy
with political debates down in the past
elections have entered the final stretch
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Rio de Janeiro